we begin with new information
from the rio grande
it is the missing texas national guard
soldier who is presumed dead drowned
trying to rescue two illegal immigrants
from the river
he has been identified 22 year old army
specialist bishop evans joined the
national guard in may of 2019
after serving in both kuwait and iraq
he was deployed at the southern border
as part of texas governor greg abbott's
operation lone star
and on friday evans bravely
went into the water
with that heavy current the rio grande
he witnessed two illegal immigrants
struggling in its strong currents
the search for his body is still
underway the texas rangers now say those
two men he was trying to save were
smuggling drugs
the silence on this from the white house
has been deafening but governor abbott
spoke out
what has happened is a tragedy shows how
dangerous it is on the border it shows
heroism
by the member of the texas national
guard who was trying to save lives
vivek we don't know why the white house
hasn't spoken yet perhaps they will make
a statement my hope my prayer is that
they're doing something more for bishop
evan's family than we would ever know
um but it seems glaring to me it does i
mean this guy first of all let's just
pause to think about this he's a
national hero he's a 22 year old
american citizen living out his civic
duty saving the lives of two drug
smugglers who he thought was we're going
to drown and i think that it's really
easy for a lot of americans to sit back
on their couches and claim their views
on immigration policy or border security
policy when they don't have skin in the
game it's one of those moments that
reminded me that actually our civic
duties ought to be shared evenly and you
know what if we did have more people
serving in the national guard i think
even civic service woven into what young
people go through you'd have skin in the
game and have very different views on
how we should be solving the border
crisis than comfortably sitting in your
homes and letting this 22 year old serve
his civic duty and die in the process
and i think that's what both democrats
and republicans should be talking about
if i were joe biden that's what i'd be
highlighting today
you know kennedy i i don't know what's
worse the fact that none of what vivic
has said is happening right now that we
know of right so we don't we don't know
what their plan is from the white house
or potentially that they don't have one
no a stunning lack of a plan is going to
make things even worse and it puts more
people at risk so far this year there
have been 11 people who've washed up on
the u.s side of the rio grande and 12 on
the mexico side and you know what what
bishop did which is so incredible is he
had a respect for human life he was
trying to save human life he wasn't
paying a picture he wasn't judging their
story or who they might be he saw two
people in trouble and put his own life
at risk and uh that is an enormous
sacrifice and you know the kind of
service that i think to your point we
have to ask ourselves would i do the
same thing would i be brave enough would
i value human life enough to do what he
did and uh it is remarkable and i i feel
so badly for his family but also you
have to realize how proud they are in
this moment like they raised that kid
right
amen i want to stay
with the soldier for just a second
texas congressman tony gonzalez tweeted
this
brave national guardsmen removed his
armor before jumping into the dangerous
waters to save human life please pray
for the families of all of those
impacted you know emily
when you see what he did and kennedy
described it so well he made a choice in
that moment
he took off what he knew
would protect him if bullets flew
so that he could go get the people
that needed his help he didn't know who
he was saving he had no idea
he risked it all yeah he made the
ultimate sacrifice based on the premise
that all lives are created equal he was
truly selfless in that moment you are
right he was an absolute national
treasure a hero
and
my heart breaks for his family of this
22 year old specialist evans who by the
way before he was serving there in that
on the river he has already served in
kuwait and iraq at this tender age of 22
and he was part of operation lone star
down there which is governor abbott's
response to the uncontrollable situation
down there the cruel situation that
president biden's policies have created
it is cruel for the migrants it is cruel
for for law enforcement border patrol
and it's dangerous
owners it's cruel for the sheriffs and
every everyone down there it has been
cruel and those lives are being lost and
in that county there have been two
drownings a week and i fear with 42
being extinguished and now the
expectation of a minimum of 18 000
migrants a day flooding over that that's
going to increase but i hope and i pray
that specialist evan's life that he
sacrificed for this wonderful country
that it won't be in vain that we will
hear from our president that he will
express an acknowledgement or a
condolence for this national hero
kaylee let's talk policy
and i know you know this so well because
you were with the former administration
that that saw this coming and tried
everything it could to turn things
around put title 42 in place not going
to sugarcoat this like we weren't having
problems before
but he really attacked this that is the
opposite of what we've seen with the
current white house it is and president
trump did turn it around at the border
yes there was a surge at a time but he
found a way with a zero tolerance policy
with title 42 with enforcing the laws on
the books to bring that under control
you have a president who with reckless
abandonment is not only apparently going
to roll back title 42 to appease aoc in
the progressives uh but elizabeth warren
on the sunday shows this week she said
quote that that the administration is
putting plans in place end quote to deal
with those demanding amnesty on the
border now demanding amnesty this is
what
senator warren tells us is happening so
what i find so interesting about what
she does and doesn't say as a
progressive is she still doesn't give
any details about what that's going to
be right she her job is to sell it
because they they're going to need those
progressives so we don't know what that
means we don't have a lot of time to
find out november is going to be here in
a heartbeat sure but what this president
has shown us is he does not care about
winning the independence winning the
suburban women he cares about sticking
with aoc it's why he's doing what he's
doing on student loans probably going to
go further why he's rolling back title
42 but if i could just say one thing
quickly about billy evans because the
story broke here on friday on
outnumbered
a tragic story of course as we learned
it and i said then you know i hope the
white house comes out and says something
swiftly expeditiously yes emphatically
they didn't but i just want to remind
everyone because we also talked about
the border whipping story here on
outnumbered how the dhs secretary
immediately essentially came out within
i think it was 48 hours said he was
horrified
it troubled him profoundly saki said
people are understandably upset
horrifying don't have the full context
they were so quick to demonize border
patrol where are they on a national
guardsman they should have been out here
immediately the politics are what
matters though the politics all of it
vivik before we scoot to a commercial i
i just want to get your last thoughts on
where the white house goes now because
they are at the heart of this really
they are at the heart of this and look i
think that we got to separate extending
a pandemic era policy where they're
actually using the pandemic as an excuse
to extend all kinds of other mandates
mandates a number of a number of other
policies voting procedures across the
country there's a number of things that
have been ex they're extended now the
pandemic has passed so what i'd like to
see is actual reform that allows them to
remove illegal migrants quickly perhaps
not even just by extending title 42
which is a pandemic error policy but
actually implementing new policies that
are tailored to that problem because
otherwise they're going to use
conservatives supporting this as a
justification to roll out a bunch of
other pandemic era emergency policies
that actually need to be extinguished
along with the pendleton i'm going to
ask our team in the booth can we roll
that from congressman cuellar real
quickly do we still have that ability
yeah here's a democrat they're listening
to the immigration activist but my
question is who's listening to the men
and women in green and in blue and more
importantly who's listening to the
border communities the sheriffs the
landowners the uh you know the rest of
the people that live on the border
kennedy well obviously senator warren is
not listening to senator cinema because
they have vastly different views of what
comprehensive immigration reform would
be and you know someone like kirsten
cinema who is very much independent uh
she stands with her state on this issue
and i i think they view immigration
differently than they do in
massachusetts yeah so you've got cuellar
in texas you've got cinema in arizona i
mean they're on the border
kelly yep yeah i mean that that makes a
lot of sense but we're all border states
now according to senator blackburn she
put that so succinctly because of the
fentanyl that's that's all over the
country now coming across our southern
border